so let's talk a little bit about the
different ways that you can manage risk
and it's generally going to fall into a
few categories you can obviously try to
avoid the risk altogether or reduce it
you could say all right that risk is
there but and I'm going to retain the
risk and then how can I manage that or
you can actually transfer that risk to
someone else and we're going to talk
about all of those so let's just pick a
particular type of risk let's say say
one risk One Financial Risk is your loss
of income what happens if you lose your
job or if you run a business what
happens if the business goes under or it
has lower income for some period of time
well the first strategy is obviously to
avoid that as much as possible or to
reduce the probability of that as much
as possible so if you're at a job try to
perform well at your job so if they're
firing folks or if they're doing layoffs
you are a crucial employee that they
can't let go that is a good way of
avoiding or at least reducing your risk
you can't completely avoid your risk
things happen in the economy no matter
how good you are at work sometimes you
can get fired you can get laid off so
always keep that in mind but obviously
we all want to reduce that as much as
possible
now that risk is there you're not going
to be able to completely get it so to
some degree you are going to retain some
of that some of that Financial Risk and
if you're taking that Financial Risk on
as we've talked about in the other
videos one of the best ways to protect
yourself is to buy is by saving money
and I would say a combination saving
money and living below your means or
having a very quick way of being able to
live below your means if by chance you
were to lose your income because if you
do that you have more time you could
live off of your savings especially if
you don't spend a lot to live and you
have time to transition to something
else now you can also transfer the risk
to others and that's usually through
some form of insurance there is
government unemployment benefits but
oftentimes that's not going to be enough
to cover your expenses and there are
other types of unemployment insurance
that you might be able to get that's a
little bit less common for people to get
you know unemployment insurance above
and beyond that so most folks are
usually when it comes to loss of income
let's avoid it or minimize the chances
of that happening but then also create a
nest egg there's other forms of risk
that we've talked about like liability
what happens if someone sues you because
you know there's a car accident and
you're at fault or at least the judge
decides or that you're at fault and then
you owe them a lot of money in a lawsuit
well once again the best thing to do is
to avoid or reduce now you can't avoid
that risk completely unless you're
willing to just not travel or not drive
or anything like that but you can reduce
it by driving safely conscientiously not
texting while you're in the car so that
you're very unlikely to be at fault if
there's any type of accident you're a
defensive driver that's always should be
the first line of attack but then on top
of that if you could retain some of that
risk obviously and the best way to
manage that is save money
Etc so that if something will happen
it's not going to be the end of the
world for you financially and what many
folks do for that type of risk and
sometimes by law in fact many states you
have to have liability insurance and so
then you are paying an insurance company
to transfer some or a lot of that risk
of liability it's usually capped to some
amount to an insurance company and I
recommend that as well especially for
things like liability so once again just
always have that in rent okay where am I
what are my risks where can I completely
avoid them usually you can't completely
avoid them but you can at least minimize
them a little bit or reduce them and
then above and beyond that since those
risks are hopefully just going to be
reduced but they're still there how much
did you take it on yourself and to
manage that you probably need to have
some savings or how much do you transfer
to others and that's probably paying
someone to ensure that hey if that thing
happened that insurance companies got my
back to a certain degree